hi I'm Michael - and I'm the lead writer
of overwatch and I'm here to break down
every character in overwatch we're gonna
start with the offense heroes dufus
started in the game as simply a name we
had this movie that announced overwatch
the world and one of the characters
mentions doom fist and just that name
was so interesting that people have been
asking us for years when are we gonna
see team fists as a hero and we on the
team were also really excited to someday
get to make him is actually a few years
ago was the first time that we even did
artwork for him and one of the amazing
things about that first look is that for
years we didn't touch it until we were
actually gonna make the hero and we
pulled it out again and we found that we
still loved it
there are a number of doom fists in the
history of the overwatch universe so
it's sort of a title that's been carried
by different characters the original
doom fist was a really good guy one of
the heroes of the omlet crisis but the
current doom fist most people would say
a little bit more of a villain Genji
Genji and Hans Oh originally started as
one hero but we had designed so much
stuff for these two characters for the
idea of this ninja samurai hybrid that
we ended up splitting them into two
characters Hanzo in development was
called Bo ninja and so Genji was called
sword ninja the story of Genji and Hanzo
as characters came from a place that you
might not expect it I really like
watching all these food documentaries
and I watch this one jiro Dreams of
Sushi which has a subplot about these
two brothers and I thought a lot about
the idea of this older brother who had
to inherit kind of his father's
restaurant and carry on that legacy and
then the younger brother who is free to
do sort of whatever he wants and so
Genji is the younger brother he doesn't
have the baggage of Hanzo he doesn't
have to worry about carrying on the
family legacy and ultimately that
creates a lot of friction between Hanzo
and Genji or Hanzo thinks that Genji's
got the good life he doesn't have any
pressure
Genji doesn't want any part of what his
family's up to and ultimately this
explodes and battle between Hanzo and
Genji leaving Genji kind of the way you
see him now which is that he was almost
killed and he had to get all this
cybernetic enhancement be over watch
that made him into the hero that you
sort of know today Genji is voiced by
Kaku space he
lots of lines both in English and
Japanese and one of the great things
having the help from gaku is that he's
sort of able to tell me like that's a
really work in Japanese let me help you
out there because I'm not a fluent
Japanese speaker McCready
when we were naming him we were trying
to come up with the perfect cowboy name
and we had these two lists of names like
first names and last names and we went
through everything
nothing was feeling quite right and
someone suggested hey what about the
name Jesse McCree jesse is a designer at
Blizzard and so we heard that name and
what okay and we kind of stacked rank
Jesse McCree against every other name
we'd come up with and at the end of it
we still thought Jesse McCready was the
best cowboy name so we ended up going
with it Jesse had to sign over his name
to us and so now he will forever be
linked to our favorite cowboy character
McCurry is voiced by the incredibly
talented Matthew Mercer funny story
about casting Mercer as McCree is that
he originally saw the game when it was
announced at Blizzcon he said like he
really wanted to be a part of the game
at that point we hadn't actually started
working on McCree yet but we had this
poster that had all the original heroes
lined up and because we like doing
things like this we snuck in a couple
heroes on the side and one of them was
this cowboy and Matt told me once he
said you know he looked at that art and
he said you know that's my be a
character I could do and that's how it
ended up Farah story is really
interesting because her whole life she
wanted to join the overwatch
organization her mom Anna is a really
prominent member of it and also her
father was a public servant and so that
sort of ran in her blood and her dream
was to someday be able to do the same
thing as a member of overwatch but
before she had that opportunity
overwatch got shut down and so now she's
a member of helix security which is sort
of like an international security
company and she's dreaming of the day
that maybe she could join overwatch
again and hopefully she'll get that
chance Reaper he was one of the original
heroes and we told very little about him
but since then we've delved into his
backstory a lot more Reaper is voiced by
Keith Ferguson who is one of the nicest
people that I've ever met so I like to
say that when we're doing boy sessions
with Reaper it's probably a little bit
of therapy for him when we did our
uprising event we were able to actually
for the first time show Reyes before he
became Reaper and so
he appears as a voice over the
communication set and I think everyone
was so surprised by it they're like wait
wait who is that he says like it Reyes
here and everyone freaked out because
they never heard kind of what he was
like before he became Reaper soldiers 76
he's actually the personal creation of
our creative director Chris Metzen so a
character that was near and dear to his
heart which he was kind enough to let us
incorporate into overwatch and so
because of that we're all very we're
very careful and we really want to make
this character that that chris loves
soldier 76 is voiced by Fred tatasciore
Sombra Sombra is voiced by Karolina
vilasa
one of the things that we were really
looking for with sombras voices we
wanted someone who had the attitude but
also had this sense of like competency
and I think Karolina really brings that
to the role we also wanted summer to be
very tough and one thing that I think
really separates her from some of the
other overwatch characters is that a lot
of the characters in overwatch have this
like heightened way of speaking they're
either very serious or they're almost
playing a role but Sombra almost sounds
like someone that you would meet on the
street and she talks in a very
naturalistic way and I think it really
sets her apart from some of the other
characters tracer she is so bright and
optimistic and cheerful like when you
hear on the battlefield she just cuts
through with that sunny voice and one of
the things that you might not think of
that is really iconic to tracer is her
giggle and we had to do so many giggles
just to like get the perfect you know
hehe well that's not a good vehicle but
we worked with a actress Karthi of old
and she has this natural giggle so we've
probably had her giggle more than
anything or any other character and we
have this library and it's always fun
when we get to do that alright so next
we're gonna talk about our defense
heroes
Bastien if I has one of the most
interesting development stories for its
ultimate which is that it transforms
into a tank that is probably the 70th or
80th ultimate ability we created for
Bastion we had trouble deciding what fit
the character it's kind of this robot
that's exploring nature and is really
fun and kind some of the other ultimate
abilities we had were you know pull out
a little remote control and it would
drive around this little drone that
would then explode that doesn't seem
quite right one time it flew and
eventually we went back to the story of
ash and said like what is this character
and the I base idea is Bastion
transforms and so we thought like is
there one more thing we could transform
Bastion into and ultimately we ended up
with a tank we feel like that actually
really fits the character and the
mobility that Bastion gets in that mode
makes a lot of sense Bastion is actually
voiced by Chris Metzen who is our
creative director he goes into the booth
and we have this whole processing setup
that transforms the sounds that he makes
into kind of the beeps and the Boop's
and the words Chris will tell you that
it's more like playing a musical
instrument than a direct translation and
I always have fun with these sessions
because I tell them to do stuff like oh
I need you to kind of sound scared so
maybe like a you know something like
that and he'll have to like yell to make
sounds like that happens so there's this
big disconnect between what the sounds
he makes and then what you ultimately
hear are and one of the hardest most
challenging things is to have Bastion
make sounds musically and once I had
Chris do that the first time I decided I
loved it so Bastion will hum Christmas
tunes he will hum kind of little musical
notes and that part is so hard for us to
do because again he can sing something
in tune but it will not translate that
way and so I'll have him there trying to
whistle the overwatch tune for like ten
minutes
Hanzo he has ultimate ability for he
fires one arrow which summons the sort
of spirit dragon that destroys like
everything is in its path and in
development it was kind of originally
blocked in using these really simple
geometric shapes and it kind of it
looked like a caterpillar so the team
would just yell during play test oh look
out is the caterpillar coming
Hanzo is voiced by Paul Makoti junk rat
if you look at him from a design
standpoint you could see that he's lost
limbs and his hair is literally on fire
because he's just fearless when it comes
to explosives junk rat is voiced by
Chris parson may is a beloved overwatch
character we cast in China to find
someone who could speak Mandarin and
also English to be able to do the role
of may and we ended up working with
Elise Jong who if you've ever met her is
basically made the character she is
happy and cute and enthusiastic and it's
just been really fun to see her in that
role or Bjorn Torbjorn from a visual
standpoint is interesting because the
overwatch team when developing the look
of overwatch wanted to take this
character and sort of evolve the look of
art that had come before from other
Blizzard games so when you look at
Torbjorn you could definitely see the
inspiration of the dwarves of Warcraft
but we really wanted to do something
else with it so we added kind of the
more futuristic elements to him and
turned him into an overwatch hero
Widowmaker recently we added a map to
the game it was a chateau and we were
creating this French Manor and we were
trying to decide well what should we do
with this and he's not like you know who
would live in a manor
widowmaker and so we decided that this
Chateau is actually the ancestral home
of widow-makers family that she's now
returned to and so when you go to the
map you can kind of see that she's in
the process of redecorating and
refurbishing the place now Widowmaker
lives in a castle and she wants you to
leave the next group of heroes are tanks
Deva ever since the omnitrices
Korea is routinely attacked you know
every couple years or so by this massive
aamna comes out of the sea and mech
pilots these mecha pilots come out to
defend the country for decades Korea
used drones to fight them off but then
won one day when this UNMIK monstrosity
reappeared it had this ability to jam
all the communications and so Korea was
forced to employ pilots to be able to
fight the threat and so when they were
looking at who the best candidates to
pilot these mech suits were they decided
to turn to the professional gamers of
Korea because of their abilities and
their gameplay strategies and the
APM and so divas sort of considered to
be the best gamers in Korea to be a
member of the squad and so she's in this
squad with these other pilots who you
know have similar skills like are there
are some other gamers and then you've
got like pilots or like a f1 driver when
we were designing Arisa we wanted to
create this character that sort of
pushed the visual design language of
overwatch and so when you look at her
she's quadrupedal she has really
interesting design elements if she sort
of doesn't look like any other hero
we've made before and certainly doesn't
look like a lot of the other robot or on
the heroes that we've created before but
because of that there were some
challenges we found that it was
difficult to relate to her because some
aspects were so unique and I remember
that we were in a brainstorm and we were
always talking about who Arisa is what
was she built for we had this idea that
she was like kind of like a police
enforcer for the city of NIMH Bonnie but
I had this idea what if Arisa was
actually built by a child and the
character of Effie appeared she's this
young genius AI roboticist who decided
that because she was inspired by all
these stories of heroes that she could
build her own hero and so she took kind
of the pieces of this old mech and then
improved them added a personality core
and when you think about Arisa thinking
about this character effets really helps
to bind the story ideas together you
could see like a recesses character that
was made by this idealistic young girl
Arisa in the story of overwatch has sort
of just been switched on like a month or
so ago so she's still really learning
about the world around her and learning
what it means to be a part of that kind
of reminiscent of another hero Reinhardt
and one of the fun things about that is
that Arisa really looks up to Reinhardt
we joke that a recentiy people i sat in
the lab together watching kind of
cartoons or seeing stories about the old
overwatch and one thing is that a lot of
a Reese's emotes and her animations are
sort of callbacks to Reinhardt in fact
she even says some of his lines
Arisa is voiced by Cheryl ski Reinhardt
he is the first hero that I worked on we
were trying to come up with the story
for this character who used the big
shield has this giant rocket hammer and
is wearing this Crusader armor just
armored head-to-toe like a medieval feet
but also futuristic Knight and we had
this idea you know he's so big and
larger-than-life that we wanted a
character that fit that and we drew
inspiration from kind of the Don Quixote
story he's currently the oldest
character in the overwatch hero lineup
and he sort of has seen it all he's been
fighting ever since the early days and
he's was sort of forced into retirement
and now he's freelancing around Europe
trying to right wrongs and we have this
idea that he's he's seen so much and he
probably should hang it up maybe he's
taken a few too many knocks on his head
but he's this guy who still feels like
he has so much to do one thing you can
see is in some of the stories he'll have
his armor off and you could just see the
wreckage of like three decades of combat
on his body he's just scarred and he has
cuts and bruises all the time Reinhardt
is voiced by Darren de Paul road hog
road hog is actually an older character
so road hog lived in the outback before
everything kind of fell apart and so for
him when he sees junker town and he sees
what's become of his home it's very sad
for him road hog has also had to find a
way to survive in this cutthroat
unrelentingly harsh wasteland and so
that's really changed him you know he
was the sort of character who just
wanted to be left alone to kind of live
on his farm but now he's had to do
things to survive in this environment
and he's really become a much darker
character road hog is voiced by Josh
Peter store Winston
we're always coming back to Winston to
look at the kind of emotional center of
the overwatch universe which is really
amusing when you think about it because
overwatch is a story about earth and we
like to explore have the diversity of
Earth and all these different places and
heroes from different backgrounds but
the one character perhaps appropriately
who carries all this is the gorilla and
he's not even from Earth he's from the
moon he's sort of taken in all these
lessons and all these feelings that
people have they started as stories but
now they're things that he truly
believes in in fights for Winston is
voiced by Crispin Freeman
[Music]
Zaria was created so that we had this
really strong female character and we
were inspired by kind of Olympic
weightlifters it must have been around
that time that you know we were watching
the competition and we felt like
wouldn't this be a cool character and so
we came up with this idea of this this
person who was about to prove that she
was the strongest in the world but at
that time on Nick's attacked her home in
Russia and she decided that it was more
important to her to fight than to
compete and so she never had the moment
to kind of get that validation that she
had trained her whole life for so
instead she gave it all up and she
became just another soldier on the
frontline
Zaria is voiced by Julia Gavin ski last
but not least are the support heroes
Anna existed as a character long before
she actually was a playable hero in the
game when we were developing Farah we
knew that we wanted Farah to sort of
come from this lineage of heroes and the
most important one of those being on
ahooo was overwatch a second command
this amazing sniper who fought during
the ominous and someone who fara really
looked up to we wanted to add a support
character who was a little more
skill-based so we thought maybe a
character who liked snipe healed would
be something that would appeal the
characters who usually played more
skillful characters but we already had a
sniper in the lineup Widowmaker and we
were wondering if the game could really
support two snipers we remembered that
we had this character in the back story
on ax and one of the interesting things
about Ana is that she eventually
disappears people believe that she's
dead but in actuality she suffers this
injury in a sniper duel with Widowmaker
she loses her eye and that actually
causes her to kind of rethink what she
wants to do with her life and it changes
her a little bit it really puts his
focus on her for protecting people in
her younger days Ana as a sniper really
saw her role as protecting people
through her role as a sniper so she
would kill people to make sure that the
people that she was on missions with
could get home safe but in the modern
day she has this weapon which is able to
heal people from range and so we're sort
of able to show how her character
changed over time ahna is voiced by
Ayesha Selim who we actually recorded
all the way from Cairo we wanted to make
this really tough older female character
because we
felt like you know entertainment and the
world could just use more of them and so
we when we settled on the idea of making
the sniper we thought on it would be
perfect because obviously as one of the
older heroes in the game we could show
that she's still really powerful and
still competent and still out there a
hero just as much as the younger
characters in the cast Lucio Lucio is
voiced by Johnny cruise and when we
heard Johnny audition for the role he
had so much enthusiasm and life once we
heard his voice we felt like there was
no way that Lucio could be anyone else
he has that personality he is exciting
and he is happy and he's just like all
about bringing people up and together
mercy mercy ultimately leaves the
overwatch organization because she has
this conflict as a kind of doctor
physician someone who's a healer she
feels like sometimes overwatch is too
militaristic in her goals and ultimately
now she's just working as a medic as a
doctor in sort of places in the world
where there are conflicts and where she
feels like she can do good recently
actually we made some changes to Mercy
so she now has a additional ability
called Valkyrie in which she can just
fly around the battlefield and her
abilities become more charged and she's
really that out of battlefield angel
mercy is voiced by Lucy Pole Moira Moira
is a very controversial scientist she
basically believes that there are too
many restrictions placed upon scientific
research he doesn't believe in kind of
taking time she believes that humans
should be a little more aggressive in
how they approach scientific discovery
and in that way she actually lines up
her philosophy very well with the
scientists of Oasis Oasis is a city that
was built in the Arabian desert in Iraq
where scientists who kind of had the
same ideas about how science should work
founded this place in the desert where
they could kind of work on science
without any restrictions and so Moira is
controversial to the greater scientific
community but to the scientists of Oasis
she's sort of right up their alley and
so they recruited her to become the
minister of genetics so she's in charge
of genetics research in Oasis we found
that people were really desiring another
support character we felt the same way
and so we created Moira we wanted her to
have a little bit different gameplay and
again we thought that the idea of a
villainous hee
would be really fun when we looked at
the talent characters we thought there
really needed to be someone to take care
of them also from a story perspective
Moira has a lot of relationships to
different characters in the overwatch
story Moira was part of Black Watch so
she knows everyone who was in the Black
Watch organization she was specifically
recruited by Reyes because Reyes sort of
identified her talent with genetics and
Reyes might have had some genetics
issues that he wanted some scientific
help with before Moira was released we
actually hinted at her in a few ways one
of the ones that people didn't pick up
so much or they obviously didn't draw
the connection was on the Oasis map
before a match would start Reaper would
mention that he's visiting an old friend
and this old friend is Moira we had this
idea of a scientist who was related to
Reyes and to Black Watch and so well we
didn't know the specific details about
the character we knew that there was the
space in the overwatching universe that
we wanted to fill so when we were
looking at who the next support
character was going to be we felt like
Moira would be a great option and her
character really came out of that Moira
is voiced by Genevieve O'Reilly Symetra
everything in overwatch is sort of
couched in this science fiction
terminology but we don't really get too
much into the nitty-gritty so when we
were developing the idea of Symetra who
is this engineer who literally creates
things in her case defenses teleporters
shield generators out of light we talked
about a number of different ways we
describe her technology for example we
said what about like photonic
engineering or something and ultimately
we decided that overwatch isn't really a
universe about the specifics of the
science that we're applying and so we
came up with this phrase hardlight which
it doesn't really mean anything but if I
tell you she engineers things out of
hard light okay I kind of understand
that and we don't have to really get
into what's going on Symetra is voiced
by Anjali bomani zenyatta sunyata is an
omni c'mon at some point in sanada's
life he had this awakening he had this
realization where he felt like there was
more to the universe than just his
pre-programmed existence he was not the
only one of the onyx that felt this way
and a number of them came together in
Nepal and formed the Shambhala monastery
which is a group of Dominic monks who
meditate about what
means to be alive and in their case what
does it mean to be alive if you are a
robot they have a belief in this concept
called the iris so they talk a lot about
the iris they believe that all beings
actually not just mechanical ones ascend
through the iris and can be transformed
into a higher state of being sunyata is
voiced by Fyodor Chen I'm Michael choo
and those were all the heroes of
overwatch we are over
[Music]